fake hate crimes and real state crimes
abound as Jessie smile it's ridiculous
story finally falls apart and the FBI is
even more ridiculous story about the
Trump campaign and Russian collusion
falls apart as well we will analyze why
we are so keen as Americans to buy these
hoaxes then why national emergencies are
not a national emergency and the wall
just got a couple hundred miles longer
I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show
[Music]
oh so much to get to so this was the day
the right was waiting for we have been
actually playing it pretty cool
Jesse Smollett came out with this story
most people on the right said okay gonna
wait for more facts to emerge doesn't
quite add up but oh no I'll wait I'll
wait
same thing with Russia collusion so you
know looking pretty bad for Democrats
right now looking kind of like there was
an inner coup d'etat that was at work
trying to overturn the presidential
election but I'm gonna wait I'm gonna
wait I'm gonna wait today is the day
we've been waiting for we will analyze
the fake hate crimes and the real state
crimes but first let's make a little
money honey with Ali Ali is wonderful
dog food your dog's health is as
important as every other member of your
family and it starts with what you feed
them but do you know what is in your
dog's food Ali puts dogs first with vet
formulated recipes and fully transparent
ingredients to give your dog the
healthiest food possible Ali makes fresh
meals for dogs with real ingredients
that people can eat and delivers them to
you on a regular schedule you heard that
right people can eat this I don't know
that I recommend it but they actually
can the big difference here is that for
most dog food according to the FDA most
dog food includes meat from the for
deeds diseased dead disabled and dying
animals actually 5ds because it actually
can include meat from euthanized dogs
and roadkill doesn't have to be that way
Ali makes fresh meals for dogs they beat
out store-bought dog food at a 10 to 1
on the palatability scale all natural
ingredients no preservatives go to my
alley com answer a few questions about
your dog they'll customize recipes to
your dog ship pre-portioned meals
they've delivered 5 million meals and
Counting shipping is free if your dog
doesn't like them they have a money back
guarantee Ali is offering our listeners
60% off your first bucks plus a free bag
of treats at my alley calm slash try
slash Knowles cane or wles this is the
best deal they have available anywhere
go to my alley comm slash try slash
Knowles keno wles 60% off plus a free
bag of treats my oli e-comm slash try
slash Knowles check it out so we now
have the identity up probably obviously
we
have all of the information yet but we
most likely finally have the identity of
Jesse smollett's white racist attackers
do we have a photo yep there it is I
always knew that Ralph Northam and Mark
herring were behind this attack I always
I always knew that the governor of
Virginia and the Attorney General of
Virginia well behind this was the most
effective blackface I have ever seen in
my life
it has broken records for costuming as
to how convincing this blackface was
only governor Northam and more Karen
could possibly have done this really
awful awful stuff it's either those two
guys or it's just two giant Nigerian
dudes who Jesse Smollett allegedly paid
to attack him and then make a big
hullabaloo out of it I again I actually
don't even now even now now you've got
the story fell apart the two guys were
caught they're not white guys they're
giant Nigerian guys Jesse's smile it
follows them on social media they go to
the same gym I guess at least one of
them was an extra on Empire which is the
show that Jesse smollett's on they are
now saying to the cops that Jesse
Smollett
paid them money to stage this attack the
attack story never quite made sense
there were a lot of inconsistencies the
Chicago PD now wants to talk to Jesse
Smollett even now I don't want to rush
to judgment but it does seem that all of
the facts are pointing to Jesse Smollett
staging this hate crime hoax and never
at any point were there really facts
pointing to this hoax being real the the
hoax
I'll let Jesse Smollett say say it in
his own words but it always seemed
pretty fake so we all know if a
conservative suspected this from the
very beginning we all suspected that
this was fake and yet America bought it
at least half of America bought it and
the question also is why did he do it
here is what Smollett says happened what
happened that night Jesse when I landed
in Chicago and Frank Gatson who's like
my uncle and he's also my creative
director and he picked me up and then we
got back to the apartment
there was no food and so I went out to
Walgreens thinking that they were 24
hours and to have a smoke walgreens was
closed so I called him up and I said hey
I'm gonna run to Subway which was across
the street and I'm gonna get a salad do
you want anything I went to the subway
and got the order during that time I
texted my manager thinking that he was
still in Australia because he was on an
Australian tour with one of his other
clients I said you know call me when you
can he called me immediately and while
he was on the phone I heard as I was
crossing the intersection I heard Empire
and I don't answer to Empire I named a
Empire and I didn't answer I kept
walking and then I heard Empire so I
turned around and I said did you just
say to me I didn't I see the attacker
masked and he said this magda country
punches me right in the face so I
punched his ass back and then we started
tussling you know was very icy and we
ended up hustling by the stairs fighting
fighting fighting there was a second
person involved
who was kicking me in my back and then
it just stopped
and they ran off and I saw where they
ran and the phone was in my pocket but
had fallen out and it was sitting there
and my manager was still on the phone so
I picked up the phone and I said Brandon
and he's likes going on and I said I was
just jumped and I then I looked down and
I see that there's a rope around my neck
there you have it an actor telling his
story in a fairly compelling way it's a
little melodramatic so immediately you
start to think not so sure about this
obviously a lot of questions come up one
if he was on the phone with his manager
why did he put the phone in his pocket
without hanging up at what point did the
phone go from he's talking to his
manager - hey okay I'm gonna put it in
my pocket now but I'm not gonna hang up
on you for some reason puts it in his
pocket and then it falls out but it
doesn't break and it doesn't even hang
up
and during this whole attack he doesn't
notice that the guys put a rope around
his neck he didn't feel it he didn't
feel the rope go around his neck he
didn't did the guys just put it there
like a like a little necklace or did
they pull on it he didn't feel anything
he just noticed it later one of the
other aspects of this story that made
people not believe it of course is that
Chicago is not mega country Chicago the
bluest state in America it was the
bluest city in America in the bluest
state in America Chicago is not mega
country one of the most corrupt Democrat
towns in the whole country this is mega
country this is there one Donald Trump
voter in all of Chicago no because they
get purged from the voter rolls maybe a
couple dead guys I don't know maybe
maybe the Democrats exhumed some dead
bodies to go vote for Democrats in the
presidential election turns out one of
them was a Republican that damn all
right we got to disenfranchise him again
the left totally believed this story
nobody on the right believed this story
the right was right as is often the case
no critically thinking person believed
this story and yet we kind of held our
tongue you said hmm
all right well I don't we don't want to
be accused of being racist we don't want
to be a clue used of not believing
victims we don't okay so how did jussie
Smollett get away with this if as all of
the facts now seem because one thing he
said the attackers were these white guys
and then he identified the attackers
walking away on camera he saw where they
were going he identifies them and then
what I guess he wasn't counting on is
that the cops were able to trace those
guys
I assume through other cameras all the
way to their apartment they had the
stuff for the fake attack and there were
these giant Nigerian dudes who knew
Jesse Smollett and who Jesse small and
knew so I think he wasn't counting on
that it's very hard to believe that he
could have mistaken these giant Nigerian
guys who the next day got on a plane for
Nigeria because they wanted to lay low
for a little while then he could have
mistaken them for white racists how did
Jesse Smollett get away with this he
puts it in his own words I'm pissed off
what is it that has you so angry
is it the
the attackers the attackers but it's
also the attacks it's like you know at
first it was a thing of like listen if I
tell the truth then that's it because
it's the truth
mm-hmm then it became a thing of like oh
how can you doubt that like how do you
how do you not believe that it's the
truth and then it became a thing of like
oh it's not necessarily that you don't
believe that this is the truth you don't
even want to see the truth the truth the
truth the truth but it's not the truth
is it
it's his truth how could you not believe
this is my truth this is the logical
conclusion of you can never question my
reality this is the logical conclusion
of radical subjectivism this is the
logical conclusion of check your white
privilege check your straight privilege
you could never possibly have an opinion
a worthwhile opinion if you are a white
straight guy about what a black gay guys
has happened because you rank lower on
the hierarchy of victimhood so you can
never challenge that opinion and that
allows liars like this guy to get away
with it and even I mean even from the
very beginning he says the guys came up
to him and yelled hey Empire first of
all nobody watches Empire right I guess
this guy's trying to save his job on
this TV show nobody I would not have
been able to pick this guy out of a
lineup I have no idea who he is before
this story came out I don't I watch
basically no TV shows because nobody
watches TV shows anymore they all just
stream shows and they'll pick one show
and binge it for three weeks and then
they'll go on to another show but this
is obviously self-aggrandizing he's
actually not a bad actor this
performance in this interview is pretty
good it's a little bit indulgent it's a
little bit acting class so you start to
he's being a little prepared he's a
little too waxing philosophical eave it
but this nobody could question it
because he says this is the truth and
you can never question now if it had
been a straight white Trump
who were claiming an attack then
everybody could question the truth
because he ranks lower on the hierarchy
of victimhood but Jesse Smollett you can
never question him even though we all
suspected it now what does he do he gets
called out even by the interviewer on an
inconsistency in his story how does he
respond in exactly the way that the
leftist culture has taught him to but
first let's make a little money honey
let's do it with ring rings mission is
to make neighborhoods safer so that you
never get jumped in the middle of the
night while you're trying to just buy a
Subway sandwich you might already know
about ring smart video doorbells and
cameras that protect millions of people
everywhere ring helps you stay connected
to your home anywhere in the world
so if there's a package delivery or a
surprise visitor you'll get an alert
you'll be able to see hear and speak to
all of them from your phone that is
thanks to HD video and two-way audio
features on ring devices I love ring
ring makes me feel much more secure I
love it so much that I have given it to
my friends I think it's a great
housewarming gift you'll feel really
cool because you can talk to people
dropping off packages people trying to
steal packages people trying to break
into your house unexpected visitors you
can talk to them whether you're in the
living room or in your bedroom or at
work or on a beach in Boca it doesn't
matter you can do it all through the
cloud if they steal your ring doorbell
if the burglars want to steal the
doorbell you can have it already
uploaded to the cloud so it's fine you
can send it to your neighbors it's
fabulous as a listener you have a
special offer on a ring starter kit
available right now with a video
doorbell and motion-activated floodlight
cam the starter kit has everything you
need to be building a ring of security
around your home just go to ring.com
slash Knolls keno wles
ring comm slash Knolls so Jesse Smollett
in this interview gets called out on an
inconsistency in his story which is that
he didn't call the cops right away
why wouldn't he has this attack its
major attack he's racist hate crime he
recovers he's got a noose around his
neck I guess but he doesn't call the
cops right away why not I don't have any
doubt in my mind that
that's there never did why did you
hesitate to want to call the police you
know there's a level of pride there we
live in a society where as a gay man you
were considered somehow to be weak and
I'm not weak
I'm not weak and we are as a people are
not weak so only I can accept that there
was pride there there's also privacy you
know at the end of the day look what has
happened wait I don't underst
he says well it's because of society
that I didn't call the cops
yeah yeah that's the ticket Society why
was it society because gay guys are
considered weak so I didn't it was prey
I was pride and society and I didn't
want to be considered weak then why are
you on national television right now
talking about it if you didn't want this
to come out if you wanted to keep this
private then why not keep it private
well I didn't want to tell the cops I
didn't want to seem weak I'm perfectly
happy to go on national television and
cry on camera about it hold on let me
see let me try to work through my old
hoggin techniques let me see if I can
okay I'm gonna try to turn from the
inner life and see if I can force myself
to cry right now okay but I don't want
to see you don't want to seem weak
really bad argument I think he got
caught on it and that was the best that
he could go to and it was effective
when in doubt when you're called out on
your lies feign victimhood Oh Cassio
Cortez does this all the time she's done
it to me I'll point out some lie that
she's told she actually a classic
example she lies about where she grew up
she pretends to have grown up in the
Bronx she actually grew up in a really
ritzy town in Westchester I then pointed
this out on social media and she accused
me of man splaining she accused me of
erasing her identity of she played the
victim she played the liar victim how
dare you call me a liar I'm a victim and
that's what Jesse Smollett is doing here
it's why I'm a victim and that's why I
didn't do the obvious thing that I
should have done when I was attacked
then the story gets even weaker because
actors just they can't help themselves
they have to get carried away with this
so he it's not enough that he got jumped
by these racist white Trump supporters
allegedly you know these racist white
giant Nigerian Trump supporters that
he's friends with but he then has to
make the story even more fantastical if
he had just left the story at that maybe
he could have gotten away with it but he
just had to go even further beyond the
realm of credulity during that time
before they came took them about maybe
half hour to come and during that time I
was looking at myself just like checking
myself out I saw the bruise on my neck
you know like the little the ropeburn
around my neck and then I said but I
smelled bleach I know the smell of
bleach and I saw on my sweatshirt it had
marks on it like spots on it when you
have a bad bleach job so he smells
bleach okay he also says later on that
he wouldn't take the rope off he left
the rope oh why does he leave the rope
on he said because I wanted to show them
I wanted them to see what happened but
if he wanted them to see what happened
why didn't you call the cops right away
you can't he keeps having it both ways
in this argument which is one of the
main signals that had conservatives
questioning him and then had him
retaliating he didn't take the rope off
he then conveniently found some drops of
bleach not on any place that would have
hurt him but just on his clothing just a
few drops so now we have to believe that
in Chicago oh by the way it was possibly
the coldest night of the year when this
happened it was during that polar vortex
a bitterly bitterly cold far below zero
we are to believe that there was a
roving duo of racist white Trump
supporters carrying around a noose and
bleach looking for a somewhat known
black actor to attack and then just to
attack and then to leave without really
hurting him
or stealing any of his property
including his sandwich which he still
had that's what we have to believe at
this point and then by the way when the
cops got there he asked them to turn off
their body cameras he actually admits to
this he said you can come into my
apartment turn off the BI it's okay we
don't need any more footage okay it's a
maybe you didn't want them to catch any
consistencies
inconsistencies rather and then he's in
this interview he knows that some
conservatives are out there questioning
him and listen to how he indict s--
Americans and how he indict his own
country you know it's two o'clock in the
morning you're going to subway Sutter is
open 24 hours
like people kill me when they say things
like that because it's like Subway is
open 24 hours for a reason so that when
you hungry at night and you ain't got no
food you go to Subway the the camera
facing north how is that my issue it
feels like if I had said it was a Muslim
or Mexican or someone black I feel like
the doubters would have supported me a
lot much more a lot more and that says a
lot about the place that we are in our
country right now the fact that we have
these fear mongrels these people that
are trying to separate us and it's just
not okay yeah it's not okay those hate
mongers and fear mongers who are trying
to divide and separate us jussie
Smollett yes that is not okay actually
though his points not true he said he
said if it were or no I guess actually
he's making a very cogent point he said
you know if it were black people who had
done this to me if I had said it was
black people then I feel like people
would have believed me and that's true
now it looks like it was black people
and I finally do believe you're Jesse
Smollett because you're finally telling
the truth or the truth at least came out
in spite of you not telling it this is
what the left does the left projects the
left always projects say these hate and
fear mongers who are dividing this
country these liars you're the hate
longer you're the fear monger you're
dividing the country you're the liar
you're the guy you're the one doing this
this is the projection and the
projection by the way is not why is he
doing this one he's trying to protect
his job on the show I guess but there is
a broader cultural point here and this
is not a
unless crime by the way there were a lot
everybody jumped on this to defend him
and to indict white male Trump
supporting America up to an including
Nancy Pelosi they haven't apologized
Nancy Pelosi hasn't apologized the left
is always projecting but I love this
Jesse smollett story I actually loved
what he did because he's exposing the
left and he's exposing their lies not
just on this issue but on many other
issues he even makes the point for us on
the Cavanaugh hearings he even in Deitz
people like Christine Blasi forward in
his hoax the next time that you see
someone report something maybe well
after the fact that it happened and you
say to them well why you wait until now
just remember that mine was reported
right away
oh we will remember that Jesse we will
remember that you reported yours right
away saying look mine was reported right
away and people didn't believe me they
should believe these people who make up
stories 35 years later like Christine
Blasi Ford and then contradict those
stories with other stories you know
unfortunately with hoaxes like that 35
years later you can't really come down
and prove it definitively one way or the
other but he reported his right away and
it was disproven all almost certainly
disproven Jesse Smollett would have had
better luck if he waited thirty five
years maybe then he could have gotten a
job on the reboot of Empire or whatever
others show he's gonna have he's making
our point for us in this he's making the
conservative point for us and it's not
just him
there have been hate crime hoaxes galore
in recent years just a few examples in
April 2015 Utah man was robbed twice by
bigots who force-fed him bleach and
carved died and then a gay slur into his
arms they got it could see the carving
the the bigots force-feeding him bleach
he later admitted he made all of that up
totally made-up
that was the purported victim who
admitted he made it up last April
abortion activists reported to police
that a pro-life
attacked her turns out that didn't
happen at all totally fake
2015 a leading gay marriage activist in
Ohio faked his own abduction so he said
he was abducted for supporting him nope
not true he just it was a total hoax
year before that a lesbian admitted to
faking anti great gay hate crimes to get
out of doing her homework if it works I
don't know I've done a lot of things to
get over doing homework that same year a
transgender dude lied about a sexual
assault hate crime in a high school
bathroom not true year before that a
lesbian waitress doctored a bill from
one of her customers to include anti-gay
slurs and to pretend that there was no
tip turned out actually the people
didn't write any anti-gay slurs and they
did tip her but she wanted to pretend to
be the victim she wanted to pretend that
there was anti-gay bigotry and animus
all over the place same year a lesbian
carved a cross into her own chest to
fake a hate crime we then found out it
wasn't true the Southern Poverty Law
Center in 2016
breathlessly reported that a black doll
was found hanging from a noose in an
elevator turns out it wasn't hanging
from a noose at all there was just a
little string that was part of the doll
there so actually what happened is
someone left a black doll in an elevator
someone left a toy in an elevator of
course you never hear any reported
apologies from these people same year
someone hung a sign at their home two
years ago three years ago now I guess
2016 it said you can hang a n-word from
a tree equal rights he'll never see this
was widely reported all the awful racism
and Trump's America turns out the guy
who hanged that sign was a black guy and
it was his own home that he hung it
outside of that's it it was just a total
hoax 2017 in Indiana there was a Nazi
anti-gay proton vandalism at a church
turns out it was the work of an
anti-trump gay man and this gay man said
he actually gave away the whole store
one I'm naming a tiny little handful of
all of the hate hoaxes that have gone on
in recent years why did he do it he said
that the 2016 presidential election had
left him quote fearful scared and alone
and he quote wanted other people
to be scared with me so the 2016
election provoked fantasies in this
man's head the leftist narrative is a
fantasy he's entertaining the fantasy
and that's why he's scared fearful and
alone but other people are not because
they're living in reality so he wanted
other people to be afraid to be living
in that fantasy with him so what did he
do he took his fantasy and he tried to
make it a reality he tried to make
himself a victim because victimhood
carries great currency on the one hand
and also because if he's living in a
fantasy and he feels alone living in
that fantasy he wants other people to
live in fantasy with him and he has to
turn the fantasy in reality why do we
buy these why do we buy these stories
why did the whole news media buy this
ridiculous story we'll get to that in a
second we'll also get to real state
crimes in a second and if we have time
at the end we will have to talk about
the wall and the national emergency but
first it's almost time for our next
episode of the conversation featuring me
little old Michael Noel's tomorrow at 7
p.m. Eastern 4 p.m. Pacific I will be
taking all of your questions every query
that is burned in your hearts and I will
answer them live on air Plus Alicia will
also be there that's pretty good as
always this episode will be free for
everyone to watch on Facebook and
YouTube but only subscribers can ask the
questions once again subscribe to get
your questions answered by yours truly
little ole me at 7 p.m. Eastern 4 p.m.
Pacific and join the conversation if
you're on Facebook and YouTube go to
daily wire.com
we appreciate you if you already there
you help keep the lights on you keep Co
FFA in my cup we have a lot more to get
to today you know you'll get me the
intro clip and show the bench go show
them that wall show ask questions in the
mailbag coming up on Thursday ask
questions in the conversation ask
questions backstage you get another
Kingdom you get everything you get this
this is the special mm-hmm-hmm taste
like the truth leftist ears tastes like
the truth not like those crocodile tears
you just saw on TV this tastes like the
truth and the truth has never tasted so
good go to daily wire comm we'll be
right back with a lot more
why do we buy these hoaxes one because
we don't want to rush to judgment
against the accuser oh good
okay that's actually a noble thing yeah
that's why I keep actually putting
caveats in here I mean the overwhelming
preponderance of evidence seems to show
that Jessie smollett's staged this whole
thing is a hoax but even then I I don't
want to totally write off the
possibility that there's something even
more going on it's that's a noble thing
to try to protect accusers it is cruel
also to rush to judgment against the
accused use and because narratives flip
all the time you saw this with those
Covington high school kids the whole
presidential Democrat candidates the
news media even bishops piled onto these
kids before any facts were and then they
look like fools it's it's cruel against
the accused because what Jesse Smollett
did was come in a real hate crime
against white people and against
straight people and against
conservatives and Trump supporters he
committed a crime against us he smeared
us he spread calumny he defamed us he
filed a false police report but it seems
like that those are real crimes this is
not a victimless crime he did something
very wrong he could go to jail for this
by the way as he should if he's guilty
the network's spent according to News
Buster's 101 minutes breathlessly
covering the story before it fell apart
we buy this and buy I mean I don't mean
us I mean the left and I mean half of
America and the mainstream media and
presidential candidates and Nancy Pelosi
we buy this because we buy the cultural
narrative that marginalized people are
hopelessly oppressed in this country and
it's a horrific country that is always
trying to kill them not just to press
them but kill them there was a headline
in the Washington Post at read quote I
doubted Jesse Smollett it breaks my
heart that I might be right it breaks
your heart that half the country isn't
anti black white racists who are trying
to maim and kill people that breaks your
heart it does break her heart she wishes
that were the case because then her
narrative would be true then her holy
beautiful narrative that America is
hopelessly
racist and vicious and bigoted and white
people are the devil and Trump
supporters are the devil that would then
that would be true she wishes that that
were the case unfortunately for her
America is a pretty good country and
marginalized communities are not really
oppressed she's so sad about that she
said quote I wanted to believe smollett
I really did I know that there was a
deep dark racist history in Chicago and
if proved true this would have just been
one more point on the list I wanted to
believe him with every fiber of my being
when was the last time a Republican ran
the city of Chicago when was that are
you talking I mean maybe yeah there are
a lot of problems in Chicago a lot of
guns a lot of terrible violence a lot of
terrible governments in Chicago all true
not caused by Trump supporters not
caused by white straight male big-daddy
patriarchy that's a good thing too
perverted people like this Washington
Post editorial assistant that's a bad
thing but to normal right thinking
people that's a good thing so why did
Jesse Smollett do it if he did it in
part there's a selfish reason in part
there's a cultural reason one what is
being reported down is that he was gonna
be written off of the show Empire and he
didn't want to be written off of Empire
so he decided to try to get some
headlines and make it such that he
couldn't get written off how did he know
this would work though I mean if that's
true or not I don't really care the
selfish reasons whatever he knew that
that would work because our culture
rewards victimhood victimhood carries a
special currency if you can pretend to
be a victim that is that will help you
socially we talk about white privilege
we talk about straight privilege we talk
about male privilege in our culture
today those are not privileges those are
disadvantages and actually the
privileges are to be the opposite the
privileges are to be marginalized
so-called so if you're a racial minority
if you're a woman if you're gay if you
are confused about your sex those are
the advantages and those are the
privileges in the hate hoax culture
privilege is the opposite of privilege
why did these other people commit the
hate hoaxes put Jesse Smollett aside for
a second because some of them believe
that the narrative is true that guy gave
the whole story away he said I just my
fantasy I know I want people to feel
my fantasy but he doesn't think it's a
fantasy he thinks it's reality they know
that the narrative is true he may they
say this all the time they say well even
if this event wasn't true it gets to a
greater truth no it doesn't this is like
Alexandria Ocasio Cortes saying well
something might not be factually true
but it's morally right no it's not in
order to be morally right you have to be
factually right you can't have a fantasy
be reality
you can't contradict reality and say
that that is reality that is what the
left wants us to do but that isn't the
case so what they do is they try to make
the events fit the narrative they staged
these hoaxes to show people the deeper
truth there's no deeper truth it's a lie
Nancy Pelosi tweeted out quote the
racist homophobic attack on Jessie
Smallin is an affront to our humanity no
one should be attacked for who they are
or whom they love I pray that Jessie has
a speedy recovery and that justice is
served
may we all commit to ending this hate
once and for all she tweeted that out
now she quietly over the past two days
deleted that tweet because she is
finally admitting what we all suspected
no apology no apology two white straight
male Trump supporting America and no
none of that from Nancy Pelosi smeared
the whole country defamed the whole
country no no no no apology to America
she's in dining America as a bigoted
awful place no apology to her countrymen
she just quietly took it down Nancy's
right justice should be served we should
end hate once and for all actually by
the way just a usage note the noun is
hatred not hate hate is a verb it can be
an adjective hatred is the preferred
noun
hatred some people think this is ironic
it's not hatred always does this hatred
always flips the script for you hatred
makes you stupid it makes you think less
clearly and when you are responding
angrily or reflexively you when you're
accusing somebody else with hatred
usually you're accusing yourself it's
like a boomerang it flips right back on
you I just just anecdotally I see this
happen all the time
the left accuses me of hatred all the
time I don't usually get angry with them
because I understand how they've
convinced themselves to think that there
of all these
is that the right understands the left
much better than the left understands
the right
I understand how through their perverse
premises and their perverse arguments
they can arrive at the conclusion that
just I don't know
citing historical facts is hateful i I
see how they get there they're wrong but
I actually can see how they get there it
you you if you don't have any self
reflection if you're just constantly
reflexively angry all the time
you're probably accusing yourself of the
thing that you're accusing the other
person of Pelosi and the left should
have some self reflection but they won't
now that's the fake hate crime we've got
to get to the real state crime because
the other big bombshell over the weekend
is this Andrew McCabe stuff we finally
got his whole sixty minutes interview
where he Andrew McCabe disgraced FBI
official he leaked on Thursday and
Friday
you saw early tapes of this that there
was a planned coup d'etat the deep state
the DOJ and the FBI were trying to
conspire and scheme to overturn the
presidential election get the president
kicked out of office now Andrew McCabe
has released his lurid details about
this because he's trying to sell a book
and he is throwing Attorney General or
Deputy Attorney General rod Rosenstein
under the bus in all of this Rosenstein
apparently had offered to wear a wire
when talking to the president to
secretly record his conversations with
the president now rod Rosen Steinem said
I was just joking it was sarcastic n'ver
McCabe says no way the Attorney General
offered to wear a wire into the White
House he said I never get searched when
I go into the White House I can easily
wear a recording device they wouldn't
know it was there now he was not joking
he was absolutely serious and in fact he
brought it up in the next meeting we had
I never actually considered taking him
up on the offer I did discuss it with my
general counsel and my leadership team
back at the FBI after he brought it up
the first time the point of Rosenstein
wearing the wire into a meeting with the
president was what what did he hope to
obtain I can't characterize what rod was
thinking or what he was hoping at that
moment but the reason you would have
someone wear a concealed recording
device would be to collect evidence and
in this case what was the true nature of
the president's motivation and calling
for the firing of Jim Comey so McCabe is
doubling down he's saying Rosenstein is
lying he was not joking about this he
was definitely gonna do this you got to
remember though Andy McCabe is the scum
of the earth and he's a confirmed liar
we now know he is a liar he lied to
investigators he lied about leaking
information to the media and he was
fired from the FBI and disgrace so we
can't just believe everything McCabe is
saying but I also don't trust rod Rosen
Stein or anyone else at the DOJ we know
that there have been shenanigans here so
we have to parse what do we believe from
McCabe what do we don't first of all
what did rod Rosenstein ever do to Andy
McCabe did Rosen Stein sleep with
McCabe's wife or something he's just
throwing this guy under the bus and
saying yeah the guy who was still the
deputy AG yeah he was plotting to
overturn the presidential election and
kick the president out of office now the
question this raises is what will happen
to rod Rosenstein will the White House
fire him how is he still on his job will
they believe Rosen Stein / McCabe McCabe
is a totally execrable figure now Andy
McCabe goes on and discusses the
possibility of Rod Rosenstein secretly
recording the president why they'd
consider doing it why they ultimately
didn't do it the general counseled the
FBI and the leadership team you spoke
with said what about this idea I think
the general counsel had a heart attack
and when he got up off the floor he said
I that's a bridge too far we're not
there yet that it wasn't necessary at
that point in the investigation to
escalate it to that level that's correct
wait wait wait now did you hear that cuz
he said oh no the council he said that
he even fell on the floor he thought it
was such a crazy idea to secretly record
the president no no he said we couldn't
do that yet catch that little yet in
there hold on a second if this is such a
shocking crazy thing
why would he leave open the possibility
to doing it later sometime in the future
oh my gosh it's such a crazy shocking
idea I'm falling on the floor man let's
hold off on that for a couple weeks
that's what he's saying so he's saying
that even at that point the DOJ was
considering secretly taping the
president having his Deputy Attorney
General go in and secretly record the
president the lawyers could envision a
world in which they actually did this
and then they get to the heart of it
what were they really going after
they're gonna record the president to
what end try to catch him in something
catch him in a crime and catch him and
catch him seeming a little erratic what
they actually wanted to do is use the
25th amendment to throw the president
out of office for incapacitation
discussion of the 25th amendment was was
simply rod raised the issue and
discussed it with me in the context of
thinking about how many other cabinet
officials might support such an effort I
didn't have much to contribute to be
perfectly honest in that conversation so
I listened to what he had to say but to
be fair it was an unbelievably stressful
time I can't even describe for you how
many things must have been coursing
through the Deputy Attorney General's
mind at that point so it was really
something that he kind of threw out in a
very frenzied chaotic conversation about
where we were and what we needed to do
next what seemed to be coursing through
the mind of the Deputy Attorney General
was getting rid of the President of the
United States well one way or another I
can't confirm that but what I can say is
the Deputy Attorney General was
definitely very concerned about the
president about his capacity and about
his intent at that point in time look in
fairness in fairness it was a really
frenzied crazy time I mean the person we
wanted to win the presidential election
lost and the person we didn't want to
win won I mean so in fairness in
fairness it's perfectly reasonable to
have a coup d'etat to launch an
unconstitutional coup d'etat overturn a
presidential
because the person we wanted to win here
you understand this the person that we
voted for lost and we weren't gonna
tolerate that so we were gonna overturn
the election you understand don't you by
the way this is this remains
unconsciously it's unconstitutional for
the Deputy Attorney General in this
schmuck at the FBI to try to use the
Constitution some provision of the
Constitution to overturn a presidential
election that's obviously
unconstitutional it's also
unconstitutional if the cabinet did it
the president was not incapacitated he
is not incapacitated at the moment
either he's not insane he's not in a
coma he's not he's perfectly fine so
even if the cab even if this scheme
worked this coup d'etat worked it would
remain unconstitutional for the cabinet
to try to use the 25th amendment to
throw him out so why is McCabe coming
out with this he's selling a book he's
selling a book he manages by the way to
seem almost sympathetic in this
interview unless you're listening to
what he says if you're just kind of
glossing over you're looking okay well
yeah okay that's fine he then comes out
and he obviously has a personal grudge
against Donald Trump cuz Donald Trump
ended his corrupt and crooked career and
didn't I tried to deny him his pension
denied him some of his pension I guess
and so he has this personal grudge
against Donald Trump a grudge enough to
try to help lead a coup d'etat and we
take over the White House and here's him
recounting his conversations with the
president this he's feigning being
shocked here ah this actually is
I think I'm most shocked at his
statement pretending to be shocked right
here talking to the president the
president launched into several
unrelated diatribes one of those was
commenting on the recent missile
launches by the government of North
Korea and essentially the president said
he did not believe that the North
Koreans had the capability to hit us
here with ballistic missiles in the
United States and he did not believe
that because President Putin had told
him they did not President Putin had
told him that the North Koreans don't
actually have those missiles and US
intelligence was telling the president
intelligence officials in the briefing
responded that that was not consistent
with any of the intelligence our
government possesses to which the
president replied I don't care I believe
Putin what did you think when you heard
that it's just an astounding thing to
say to spend the time and effort and
energy that we all do in the
intelligence community to produce
products that will help decision makers
and the ultimate decision maker the
president United States make policy
decisions and to be confronted with an
absolute disbelief in those efforts and
a unwillingness to learn the true state
of affairs that he has to deal with
every day was just shocking it's it's
just shocking it's just astounding that
after all the work that we spook
bureaucrats put in trying to launch a
coup d'etat and overturn the
presidential election the president
doesn't trust us can you believe that us
the people who were working with the
Democrats the DNC
Hillary Clinton to prevent him from
being president then as I just admitted
in this very conversation we people who
were trying to kick him out of office by
launching a coup d'etat using either the
Constitution as a mechanism or a fake
investigation that I personally launched
he doesn't trust us I mean what you know
you know how could he not trust us why
wouldn't he trust a bunch of Democrat
hack traitor spooks
I just don't if you can't trust a bunch
of Democrat operative traitor spooks who
can you trust you know who can you trust
now can we trust McCabe I don't know we
trust him here he's an admitted liar
he's a demonstrable liar he's a proud
liar he's a boastful liar so is he I
don't know is he just setting a broad
Rosenstein or something maybe is he
settling a grudge is he selling books is
it I don't know or is he telling the
truth
we're gonna find out though because
Lindsey Graham Lindsey Graham Bowe is
promising to a NAB McCabe for lying you
know he's going to try to subpoena him
bring him back to testify so we'll be
able to catch the inconsistency
they'll NAB and either he was lying in
the interview he was lying to
investigators before he's lying to the
Senate we'll see what happens it's gonna
produce a lot more wonderful tape and I
just love this is the first moment in
this whole investigation where you're
just starting to see a little light on
this you're being to see a little light
on the corruption at the DOJ you're
seeing a little light on the corruption
of the bureaucracy working with the
Clinton campaign with the Obama
administration using the power of the
state to work with the Clinton campaign
and President Trump and conservatives
and Republicans are coming out smelling
like a rose
more light bring on the light we'll get
somewhere that tomorrow in the mean time
I'm Michael nose this is the Michael
Nolt show see tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Noel's show is produced by
Robert Sterling executive producer
Jeremy more senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer is Mathis
clever and our technical producer is
Austin Stephens edited by Dani D'Amico
audio is mixed by Dylan case hair and
makeup is by Jessa alvera production
assistant Mick Chien the Michael Noel's
show is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 20 19